mirages
appear when you drive along a road on a
very hot day and the tarmac the asphalt
on the road is very hot so you wouldn't
want to put your bare feet on it and
suddenly on a flat road if you're
driving the right direction you can see
the sky as if there were a puddle in the
road reflected in the road so that the
light from the sky comes down
and seems to hit a puddle and be
reflected up into your eye this is
called an inferior mirage because it's
below the horizon it's underneath the
horizon it's called inferior i mean it's
blooming wonderful it's not inferior in
that sense it's because it's below
and the explanation for these
observations was given by pierre de
fermat the famous french mathematician
he was a brilliant mathematician and he
wrote to somebody and said the reason
light travels in these funny lines is it
doesn't travel in the straight line as
people would imagine it goes along the
path which takes the least time
so the the question this raises is
under what circumstances could this
possibly happen
well imagine that light travels at
different speeds and different parts of
space it's just as though you were going
to another place through a muddy field
and if you travel in a straight line
through this money field it would slow
you down because it's so boggy
alternatively you're going a footpath in
a detour to come around from the other
side and that might be the quicker and
more sensible route well in the same way
light could find that in some medium
such as water or air it
prefers to go in a region where it can
speed up because then it can get there
quicker practical example i'm going to
talk about a car on a road
uh traveling along on a very hot day
such that the tarmac gets
inaudibly hot you won't want to tread on
it and the air next to the tarmac gets
very hot
and as a result it expands
whereas the air further up is cooler
and as a result it's it's slightly more
dense now light travels faster in this
less dense air than in this cooler air
so imagine this is a bit of the sky
actually it's my filing cabinet and the
light is i don't know i'm going to
exaggerate this because it's not on this
scale the light comes down from there
gets near this hot air
and it rises up to my eyes and this path
takes advantage of the fact that the
light is traveling faster near the
ground than up in the air
and compared to any other path that it
might come slightly higher up or further
down this is the path which is locally
going to take the least time so what i'm
going to see as i look
at the camp my filing cabinet
i'm going to see the sky or above it but
if i look down here this ray bends up
comes into my eye and i see it as if
there were a mirror on the floor and
this mirror is reflecting the sky into
my eye there's another kind of mirage
not an inferior one but a superior one
and now in this case you look at the
horizon and it's maybe the sea and you
can't see anything there
but
the light now is bent the other way
because just above the sea surface it is
very cold it might be the polar ice caps
or the region near there and further up
in the air the air is hot so instead of
bending this way it now bends that way
now the earth is spherical so we can see
things
from beyond the actual horizon and they
rise up come up into the atmosphere and
come down again and as i look up at it
it seems to be floating in the sky
this is the
superior image it comes above the
horizon people called it in italy
the fatter morgana because it was seen
in italy in the straits of messina and
they thought these wonderful shapes that
they were seeing were created by a witch
morgan le fay the the half-sister of
king arthur and she was producing these
funny shapes in the sky that they
couldn't explain so fermat came up with
this this idea but it was rubbish by
everybody they couldn't believe that
light an inanimate object or concept
could actually have a brain so as to be
able to work out which path would take
the least time that doesn't make any
sense
the only problem with this criticism is
that this idea works
it fits all known experiments so
although intellectually you might think
this is stupid every time you use it to
make a calculation it explains what you
see here's an example on a practical
level i'm going to talk about the
reflection of light off a mirror so
imagine this is a mirror
and i'm standing up oh i make this in a
human being over there and the light
goes from this person to that person and
it can go in any sort of path and i'll
work it out the path which takes the
least time and you draw all these paths
out
and the one that takes the least time is
a symmetrical one where the angle of
incidence in here is equal to the angle
of reflection this is one of the the
well-known laws of snell
alvin of course light will go along this
path but this path
along here going from one to the other
is the one that's going to take the
least time compared to all the other
piles locally that there are and that's
why we don't see a million reflections
we just see the one in the mirror down
here and we see the other one directly
in front of us so you are seeing the sky
in the ground and you're seeing the sky
directly
so you only see these two images so now
you understand that the light can travel
from one to the other in a direct path
but can also go on this path and what's
happening when there's a mirage is the
light will come from this figure and
come down and go up as a parabola like
that and other paths are possible around
here but they don't contribute just as
these other paths don't contribute and
only that one adds up
to create an image that you can see here
is an ordinary mirage there is the road
there is
the bit acting as a mirror so you can
see this blue car reflected in the road
imagine the light not coming from the
sky but coming from this car and the
light coming towards us from this car is
coming down
and then turning up and coming up at an
angle so we actually are seeing a
picture of that car turned upside down
in the road acting as if it were a
mirror